Okay,
welcome back.
Hope you had a good break.
Can you remember back to when we before break,
we were talking about the last thing we did was this a gyroscope bicycle wheel
precession to show what would happen to a nucleus that was spinning in a
magnetic field or um,
uh,
an electron for that matter.
Just to rehearse it a little bit,
remember the idea of a pulse of 90 degree pulse.
If you,
if you have a big magnetic field,
the blue one,
they are really enormous.
And then the little magnet of the,
um,
of the nucleus,
uh,
precesses at a hundred megahertz,
for example,
in a certain field,
right?
And that gives rise to a constant vertical field,
but a rotating horizontal field from that one.
So the question is whether that rotating horizontal field,
which is UC,
it will be going back and forth and back and forth,
will act as an antenna and give you a signal.
You should,
you should be able to pick up a radio signal at 100 megahertz.
Indeed,
you should be able to accept that there's not just one proton.
There are lots of protons and they're in different phases of precession,
right?
So although they all add vertically and you have a substantial vertical
magnetism from those,
they're horizontal components cancel,
right?
So you don't see anything.
In fact,
the energy is so small of the interaction of each of these magnets with the
field,
that there are one's pointing the opposite direction with higher energy,
almost exactly the same population.
Just a tiny,
tiny difference.
But we'll look just at the excess.
Obviously one's down,
we'll cancel ones up,
okay.
But if we look just at the net ones up,
even they cancel because there are different phases of rotation or a precession
about that access.
Okay?
But you can do a trick.
I remember we could,
we could,
um,
uh,
consider that we're rotating with them so that they look like they're standing
still.
And then in our frame,
we'll put on a little bit of a magnetic field that's horizontal,
a very weak field.
And now as far as we can see,
we don't care about the big field anymore because we've compensated for it by
orbiting around this thing is we're looking at it,
right?
But what we see is that these will begin to precess in our frame around that
horizontal field.
So they'll do a slow precession all of them in that direction.
So there'll be going like this,
I'll start here,
they'll go there,
then they'll go down and they'll go back and then back up again,
right?
But we're going to put on a pulse only long enough of this field so that they go
down to here.
Okay,
that's called a 90 degree Pauls.
And they'll rotate down like that.
And now forget the rotating frame.
They'll look like they're just pointing out toward us in the rotating frame.
But if we go back to the real frame,
the laboratory frame,
what we see is this whole bunch priestessing around the field,
right?
And now as they precess around the field in the laboratory frame,
There will be a net horizontal field that they're generated,
magnetic field and that will be the antenna that broadcasts a signal that we can
hear.
Okay.
And what will determine the frequency of that signal that's going to be coming
out from going back and forth and back and forth or around what will its
frequency be?
How rapidly are they processing
says a hundred megahertz and what determined the 100 megahertz,
the strength of this big magnetic field.
Remember,
the more you twist on something,
the faster it precesses,
right?
So we could make it a hundred megahertz.
If we had half as big a big field,
it'd be 50 megahertz or twice the field,
it'd be 200 megahertz and so on.
Okay.
So we get a signal that's a hundred megahertz radio frequency in the laboratory
frame that we could detect with an antenna,
okay.
But in time it will relax.
This is a non equilibrium situation.
When we put the energy in to make you go down and in time it'll come back to
equilibrium.
And that process is called relaxation.
And there are various things that control how fast that happens,
right?
But,
but it will reestablish equilibrium and it will be very important later in the
lecture about this relaxation.
And you'll see why.
Okay,
so in 90 degree,
pulse makes the Spinning Nuclei,
protons are see thirteens broadcast a frequency that tells what's their local
magnetic field is.
The higher the field,
the faster they precessed the higher the frequency.
Now let's first look at this as,
as it arises in magnetic resonance imaging,
where the purpose is to locate protons within the body using a nonuniform
magnetic field.
Now the idea of tomography is important here.
I've taken this from a Colorado physics 2000 page,
okay?
So this is a slice through somebody's body,
show their ribcage,
spine,
and so on.
And they're wearing some sort of jacket that's opaque to x-rays.
Okay?
And we're interested in,
in finding what it looks like inside.
Okay,
where are these things are?
So what we do is we take x rays and send an x ray beam straight through and see
how much gets through.
And we scan the xray from top to bottom and see how much gets through it.
Every different x coordinate.
So we do a scan and it starts at the top,
but oops,
there's something there and there's even more there and lots then a little bit
more and when we hit the spine there's going to be quite a bit right and so on.
But that's just a one dimensional picture of the density,
okay?
Now what we're going to do is take that same picture and just smear it out to
the right,
okay,
so that's the profile top to bottom or stomach to back,
right of this particular slice through the body of bones or whatever it is,
okay?
Now the neat trick is that you rotate that,
rotate it by 15 degrees and now do the same thing again and super impose the new
one on the old one and now rotate another 15 degrees and do the same trick scan
top to bottom.
And I had it up and do it again and again and again and again and again,
again,
again and again and see what you got.
Now
when you super impose all of those,
you get what it looked like,
the two dimensional slice through the thing,
so that's called Tomography.
If you can tell,
if you can get a one dimensional projection and do it in lots of different
directions and add them together,
you can get the two dimensional,
Laura,
in fact,
a three dimensional picture of what's going on inside.
So that's the trick that's used,
except you want to do it for protons,
not for bone.
Okay?
So we want to find protons in the body.
For example,
let's find where there's fluid water in the body,
okay?
So there's a body,
And we put it inside this cylinder and wrapped the cylinder with special wire
that if we cool it to liquid helium,
temperature is superconducting.
So essentially we've made a big solenoid magnet,
okay?
That goes along the body's axis,
Now what will happen?
Well,
suppose that field is 1.5 Tesla,
which means 15,000 cows.
A Gaussian,
remember is about the size of the earth's magnetic field,
more or less.
Okay,
so 15,000 times as strong as the earth's magnetic field.
Okay?
So what will happen to the protons in there?
Well,
they're gonna precess,
right?
And in that field at 15,000 cows or 1.5 Tesla,
they'll precess at 63 megahertz,
right?
So if we put an antenna in there and give a 90 degree pulse,
we're going to hear a signal at 63 megahertz,
right?
Our radio.
We'll pick that up.
Okay,
so we know there are protons in the body,
right?
Surprised.
No.
Okay.
The question is where are the protons in the body?
Now here's an analogy to,
to figure this out.
Suppose we had a cricket in this room and wondered where it was,
but I'm blind.
I can here but with only one year,
so I can't hear it.
I don't have spatial resolution with my ear.
How can I find out where the cricket is in this room?
Anybody got an idea?
Well,
I have one bit of control over the room.
I can make a temperature gradient in the room,
make it cold in front and warm behind.
Suppose I can do that now.
How can I find the cricket?
What they're at?
Different speeds and different.
You hear Chirping,
you count how many there are in 13 seconds and add 40.
Right?
If you go to,
you establish a temperature gradient,
then you listen with a stopwatch.
And if you go to Snopes,
you can see that this is not an urban legend or a rural legend.
It's true,
right?
That you can do that.
And they actually show this picture of,
of uh,
uh,
Dr Lamone from Boulder,
Colorado who actually did this with crickets and showed that it gives a very
good measure of the temperature.
So if I could establish a temperature gradient from front to back and count for
13 seconds and had 40,
and knew what the temperature is,
I know how far from front to back,
what would I do next?
If I want to find the cricket,
I'd fiddle with the air conditioning controls and make a temperature gradient
from left to right.
Right?
And I could even make one from top to bottom and then I'd know how,
what it's excellent.
It's Y and z coordinates are okay,
so I could find the cricket that way.
So we're going to do the same thing with the protons in the water in the body.
Okay?
So back to the body here.
Okay.
What I need is not a uniform field where all the protons are going at 63
megahertz.
I want to make them faster in some regions than others.
So what I do is I put two coils around this solenoid,
and in the one near the head,
I make the current go that way,
which reinforces the field.
And in the one near the feed,
I make it go that way,
which subtracts from the field.
So now I've generated a gradient along the body,
and it turns out to be that what's actually used as about 40 micro Tesla per
millimeter,
right?
So if I went like,
uh,
25 millimeters about an inch,
right?
That would be a thousand micro Tesla.
That is a Milli Tesla,
right?
So it'd be about one part in 15,000 or pardon me,
one part that's a milli Tesla out of a one and a half Tesla,
right?
So about a part per thousand,
Difference.
Okay.
So that means if I,
if I,
um,
if I sliced,
uh,
if I sliced the body there or they're on the first slice,
remember there's a gradient from foot to head.
So they're the,
they're there.
We have the average 63 megahertz.
There's going to be a signal coming out from protons that are in that first
slice.
But in the second slice they're going to be at 63.05 about a part per thousand
higher,
right?
Because there's a higher field near the head and that if I did another slice,
another inch or so along,
it'd be 63.1 megahertz.
So if I had an antenna and could hear all these different frequencies and how
strong the signal was,
I'd get a profile of the proton distribution from foot to head.
So just like we did with the x rays scanning down,
I now how know how much water there is at different places along the height of
the body or the length of the body.
Okay.
What do we want to do next,
Matt?
[inaudible]
so we want to make a gradient in a different direction.
So I stopped the current of those green coils and put on yellow coils with
current going that way,
which adds to the the big field on the right,
right?
And then I put other coils over here,
which the current goes that way and makes it subtracts from the current on that
from the field on the left.
Right?
And when I do that,
I get a gradient from right to left,
right?
So then I can do a slice and find out how water is oriented that way.
And then I can put coils on the top and bottom analogous to these and get a
vertical gradient and get it that way.
And in fact by putting a certain amount of current in all of these coils at the
same time,
different amounts of different coils,
I can make a slice that goes any direction I want to and find out how much is
there.
Right?
So now in three dimensions I can do one of these tomographic reconstructions and
get where,
where,
where the water is in the body.
Okay.
Now much more interesting than that,
which is itself very powerful is functional.
And Mr. Our MRI,
magnetic resonance imaging,
where you locate protons,
who's signal strength is being fiddled with.
So for example,
we talked about relaxation,
how fast the signal goes away,
right?
If you measure this for d for the different signals you were getting,
how fast they went away,
then you'd know something about a difference from one part of the body to the
other that the protons in this part,
there signal is going away rapidly,
whereas here they're not,
okay.
So you could get something about how the protons are behaving,
not just what their local field is.
Okay?
So for example,
blood oxygen level dependent or B,
O,
l,
d bold imaging,
uh,
you can do this and you get a spatial resolution of about one millimeter,
right?
And the temporal resolution of about two seconds.
So every two seconds you can get where this,
where oxygen is in the body,
unusual amounts of oxygen.
Now how is that relevant?
Because if you have cell activity,
it increases the blood oxygen supply and that speeds the relaxation.
How fast the signal goes away,
right?
So now these are very weak signals.
So the way you tell something about them is to take a difference.
Where did we see a difference map before?
Do you remember?
Remember,
what do you want to look?
Look for bonds in X-ray.
We look at the,
the observed electron density minus what you'd have for the atoms.
And that different signal tells you how that's shifted for bonds.
Well you do a similar kind of thing here.
You get a different map.
Now this is a bunch of different slices through the brain.
And what's lit up is where there's relaxation.
That is where there's oxygen,
where the brain cells are active under one circumstance minus how active they
are under others.
On some other circumstance,
it's a difference,
right?
So the brain is working harder when it's in one state than the other.
Now what are the two states?
It's the,
the uh,
subject being shown donuts minus the signal when the subject is being shown car
keys.
So these are places where the brain lights up when it sees donuts but doesn't
light up when it sees car keys.
Okay.
Now this particular subject had recently been fed,
right?
And they did it also for someone who had,
who had not been fed,
who was fasting and their brain really lit up when they saw donuts versus car
keys.
So you can imagine that this is very,
very popular with the,
with psychologists and so on,
people interested in brain and all sorts of things where you can,
where you can use this trick of differences to see where something's happening
in one case versus another.
So that's MRI and of course it's not fundamentally are different.
Our business here to talk about MRI except we want to see things happening in
molecules.
Now,
why can't we do exactly the same trick with molecules to find out where protons
are in a molecule?
How do we know what that something is here rather than here rather than here in
the brain we establish a magnetic gradients so that you get a different field
here in here and you get different frequencies and you can distinguish where it
is in the brain.
Okay.
What's the problem with doing that for a molecule and looking at different
protons and molecules?
What's the difference between my brain and a molecule?
There are lots of differences,
but one of it is that I hope my brain is an awful lot bigger than a molecule,
right?
So you can't establish a gradient big enough across the small dimensions of a
molecule so that protons in different regions will have different frequencies,
right?
Within any one molecule,
it should all be the same field for practical purposes,
right?
So we do this trick,
or can we,
so we want to locate protons within molecules and now we want to have not a
gradient.
We want to have a uniform field.
We can't,
if we could make the gradient big enough,
maybe that would be useful,
but we can't make it big enough.
So let's go the other direction and make it absolutely the same everywhere.
A uniform field.
Okay.
Now and then what we're going to do is listen,
right until we hear and put up one of these pulses in,
and here are the frequency with which these protons,
if they're protons there in the sample,
we'll hear them.
Of course,
more still Ganek substances have protons in them.
So it doesn't surprise you.
That is,
I scan the magnetic field,
right?
Increasing the magnetic field,
which changes the precession frequency while listening with a radio that's tuned
to just one frequency.
As I go along,
at some place,
I'm going to have the right frequency and the protons are going to give me a
signal,
okay?
Of course,
if I had different nuclei in there that were different magnetic strengths,
then I'd get signals at different places,
right?
But I'm going to only look at pro only listen for protons.
Okay,
so there it is.
Bingo,
protons,
again,
protons.
Again,
there are different signals for protons.
Not all protons are equivalent,
okay?
Now the difference here between this signal and this signal and how big the
magnetic field is,
is very,
very small.
It differs by only that fraction,
2.48 parts in a million.
They're almost exactly the same,
right?
But they're a little bit different.
Just parts per million different.
Now this,
when this was discovered,
it was an annoyance for the physicists who are mostly interested in things like
measuring how strong the magnetic moment was,
how fast the precession was for protons,
but they put something in there that has protons and they find out there are
different protons,
which one is the real proton?
Right?
So the,
the,
they called this the chemical shift because these differences had something to
do with the chemical environment,
right?
But this was a gold mine for chemists because since the beginning,
people have been introduced since 1850 at least people have been interested in
chemical structure,
right?
But the only way they could do it was convert one molecule to another account.
Isomers as we discussed last semester with Kerner and so on,
and try to use logic to figure out what structure would be consistent,
right?
For the,
for these various transformations,
chemical transformations.
But now there was the pos and of course then there was X-ray,
which really did show where Adam's were.
But here's something that could work in liquids,
right?
Not everything can be a crystal.
So this looked really,
really promising.
Now this sample turned out was ethanol.
Now what do you think the three different signals are in ethanol?
Well,
one might,
one must be the Oah.
One must be the ages of the ch two and one must be the H's of the ch three right
now this requires doing such an experiment requires that the field be very,
very uniform.
Because if as you go from one part of your sample to another,
the field changes by a couple of parts per million,
then the methyl protons in this part of the sample will appear the same place
that the ch two protons appear in this part of the sample or the Oah does in
this part of the sample.
Even if this,
even if the gradient across the sample is only a part per million or so write a
couple of parts per million,
right,
and that's one of the reasons is these peaks are not infinitely sharp.
One of the reasons they're broad is that the field is a perfectly uniform,
but it's very good.
It's within a fraction of a part per million.
Okay.
Now in the late 1950s is it says here,
chemistry departments began buying commercial NMR spectrometers.
This one was called the variant a 60.
And it's the one I learned to operate.
Uh,
and they,
and they had to have fields that were homogeneous enough to determine molecular
structure.
So they had to have fields that were different that didn't vary by more than a
small part of a part per million.
Okay.
So that you could tell things about chemical shifts and spin,
spin,
splitting switch we're going to be talking about in the rest of this lecture.
But of course these things were expensive and many different people were using
them.
So it was a challenge to keep the field homogeneous,
to obtain sharp lines.
Now,
there were knobs in there that you could turn the current to coils to make the,
to cancel a gradient in one direction or another,
another,
another.
Right.
And most of them were hidden behind that door and the door said on it,
do not open,
right?
Because someone who knew what he was doing and came in at the beginning of the
day and turned all those knobs just right.
So the field was very uniform and if anybody else came in and twiddled them,
then the next guy to come in was really up a creek.
I so do not touch these gradient knobs.
In fact,
there was one there the why gradient,
which would have its own special sign,
do not touch this.
Okay,
now this was fine.
Uh,
but across the,
across new haven or across the long island sound,
here you see the smokestacks at Port Jefferson and the medical building at State
University of New York at Stony Brook.
And there was a physical chemist at stony brook who fiddled with them.
His name was Paul Lauterbur.
And in 1972 he would take over this machine every night and he'd just wreck the
field homogeneity.
And of course,
late at night before he left,
or early morning,
he would turn all the knobs back cause he was really an expert of Nmr.
But the reason he did this was to establish gradients in different directions so
that he could locate within,
he had a sample tube and he filled it with d two o not protons.
And in it he put two capillary tubes,
right?
That had water in them.
So he did exactly the kind of experiment we were talking about and in nature in
1973,
he published this re scanned in one scan vertically and got this and uh,
horizontally and got this scanned at 45 or minus 45 and got those and could find
out where these water samples were inside the D two o.
Okay.
And he called that Zig zagging photography.
Right.
But the name didn't catch on.
But the good news was that 30 years later he got the Nobel prize in physiology
or medicine for inventing Mri and that's when he worked on the rest of his life.
Okay.
So it was a chemist who invented MRI.
Uh,
so,
uh,
there are lots and lots of magnetic resonance spectrometers and I already showed
you some ex-ray defract Tom butters around,
which have put classical structure proof by chemical transformation.
The kind of thing that we talked about current are doing and even I are mostly
out of business,
although there are still things for which I are is as good or even better than
Nmr.
Okay.
And in fact there was a Yale before I came here,
there was a organic chemistry professor who was in the field called natural
products where the job was to take something that came from nature and figure
out what its structure was.
And the way to do it in those days was to do these chemical transformations and
try to make it from something or make it into something who structure you knew,
okay,
so these were great puzzles and it was really a big operation.
But when Nmr came along,
he abandoned organic chemistry and took up fundamental research on quantum
theory.
And in fact later he became a professional studio photographer,
right?
He was just wiped out by Nmr coming along,
which is the way people know structures.
Now,
we haven't really talked about that much about how people,
Newt,
we've talked about different structures,
but not really how people figured them out except when they used x-ray.
Right?
But this is an even more common way of determined structures routinely as
spectroscopy and in particular nowadays,
magnetic resonance spectroscopy.
So a couple of years ago I took a tour through the department and took
photographs of magnetic resonance spectrometers to show you here.
So across from your lab you may have noticed this door,
which is says chemical instrumentation center.
And it says warning over here about magnetic fields.
So if you have a pacemaker,
be careful.
Okay.
And you go inside there and some of these have now been moved since I took the
pictures.
But you see these things sticking up like here and here,
okay.
And if you,
if you go around,
you see these big,
big cans,
right?
Warning,
strong magnetic field.
Here's another one.
Here's another one that's a 500 megahertz spectrometer.
Here's a 500 megahertz spectrum and here's the 600 Megahertz Spectrometer.
Here's another 600 Megahertz Spectrometer and out in the courtyard behind your
lab,
there's this special little building that was,
was a constructed,
especially for a big magnet,
right?
And it has this one,
which is an 800 Megahertz Spectrometer,
which turns out to be eight to the third power that is 512 times as sensitive as
a 100 Megahertz Spectrometer,
not dimension other advantages that we're going to talk about below right now.
Why is it eight cubed?
It's because of the Boltzmann factor.
Remember,
this signal comes because they're more that point with the field against the
field.
We only see the difference between those two,
right?
And if you have a bigger energy difference,
you'll get a bigger population different.
So you get eightfold factor from that.
But the energy quantum that you're dealing with and going from one level to
another becomes eight times as big.
That's,
that's uh,
that's,
uh,
an advantage in your signal and the sensitivity of the electronics when it's
eight times vigor is also better.
So all of these things go together to make it 500 times better and even bet more
than 500 times better when you consider the,
what we'll talk about soon,
the chemical shift advantage.
So that's why one pays the big bucks to have a machine like that here,
here,
just some others that I took around.
And now the uh,
by the cross hall there next to your lab when you walk down there and on this
side of it,
there's a room that has electron paramagnetic resonance spectrometers.
So this is a much smaller magnet one,
not one of these big liquid helium cooled things.
And the reason is that this is the study free radicals which have magnetic
electrons,
mostly electrons come in payers and their magnetism is cancel,
right?
But in certain molecules,
free radicals,
there's an odd electron who's magnetism is detectable.
So this is the study free radicals,
right?
And the electron magnet is 600 to 660 times stronger than the proton,
So you don't need such a big field to make it precess,
right?
So,
so you can use just 0.3 Tesla instead of,
instead of several Tesla for electron paramagnetic resonance.
So there are two of those spectrometers and in fact we don't have one of these,
but there's now a commercially available a 1000 Megahertz Spectrometer,
which is 23.5 Tesla.
Okay.
And at the Florida State University natural at national high field magnet lab,
there's a field that's pulse that goes to 45 Tesla and it's a national lab.
You don't pay to use it,
but you have to have a great experiment that builds,
be assigned time to do things there.
Okay,
so there are lots of these things around.
Now let's go back and see why it's so good.
Okay.
We have these three signals and as we said,
we're interested in which peak is which set of protons.
Now how do we know which is which?
Right?
Can anybody see a way of figuring out which is the ch three which is a ch two in
which is the Oah.
Any guesses?
Yeah.
Ah,
if you,
if you have twice as many protons,
there should be twice as strong a signal.
You measure the strength of the signal by how much area is under it by
integrating it.
So if we measure the integrals we see there in the ratio of one to two to three.
So it's clear that that's the one that's the two.
And that's the three.
Now we couldn't do this and I are right because we had these normal modes and
and I had for example,
CEO and remember as the COO vibrated,
something else vibrated at the same time and other things and they could cancel
or reinforce.
So the signal intensities were very,
very different for different groups,
right?
But here,
the protons are all essentially exactly the same.
They differ only by a part per million or a few parts per million,
right?
So the intensities are proportional to the number of protons because the diff
differences,
so subtle.
So you can count protons by the area under these,
under these peaks.
That's what it says here.
The number of pro is proportional to the number of protons because they're so
similar.
Not like IRP.
Irps.
Okay,
now how can you use this?
Here was one of the very first uses of a subtle organic chemistry question.
This was an advertisement by the very end corporation in 1955 who are trying to
sell those machines.
I showed you that the guy over it,
Paul Louder or messed up the field on every night.
Okay.
So this was a example number 20,
the use of integrated intensities and structural analysis.
So there's a question of the structure of c seven h eight,
whether it's this or this,
and notice that those two are related to one another because if we shifted the
electrons like that one would go to the other.
So it's a,
you can imagine them going back and forth by an electrocycle like reaction.
And the question is,
which is it really?
Well,
you could try to figure out by chemical transformation and people did that.
Okay,
so which is it?
Well,
let's try Ozu analysis.
Now.
Do you remember what happens with Ozo analysis and then oxidation,
you cleave cc double bonds and make carbon eel groups there and acid from,
uh,
from,
make a carboxylic acid group.
When you add the h two o two.
So these would give different products.
Noticed that on the left you would cleave three bonds.
On the right,
you'd cleave only two double bonds,
right?
So on the left,
uh,
you would get that dye acid.
On the right,
you'd get the dye acid that has two more carbons,
okay?
Now in fact,
that acid on the right was known,
it's called sis carbonic acid.
And that's what you got.
So what's the conclusion?
The conclusion is that the structure must be be not a,
so that's a classical structure,
proof by chemical transformation,
okay?
But here's a completely different way of going about it.
Take the Nmr spectrum and count the protons.
Okay?
So the group on the left,
there are protons that are attached to double bonded carbons and on the right to
single bonded carbons.
Okay?
And now notice that the compound B has four of each kind,
but compound day has six of one kind and two of the other.
Okay.
And if you integrate,
you find that those ratios are 2.9 to one three to one.
So,
which isn't,
it must be a,
that you're taking the spectrum of,
okay,
that's the one,
that's three,
two,
one.
Okay.
So it must be that,
that's the structure,
but then how do you explain this misleading chemical transformation?
Right?
It must be that there's an equilibrium between these two things that lies to the
left.
So when you take the spectrum,
that's the stuff you see that's most of the material,
but it's not as reactive with ozone as the stuff on the right.
Okay?
So that little bit of stuff on the right is what reacts with ozone and gives the
product.
So the,
the chemical transformation was misleading.
And this is the kind of thing that made this a Yale natural products,
organic chemistry professor,
pull out his hair and become a quantum chemist and then a studio photographer
that you couldn't do what he was trained to do anymore.
Okay?
So spectroscopy took over in determining structure and we're going to talk a
little bit about how you do this now.
And Chemistry to 20 website has a bunch of Nar bar problems.
There are,
uh,
there are,
40 problems there.
And this,
I took this from one of them and fiddled with it a little bit.
And in fact,
let me just see,
I think I left an extra,
well,
I'll go through here and there's going to be an extra slide in hearing it.
Okay.
So we can integrate and see that there are two and three and three,
right?
So we know that the two must be that ch two,
but there are two ch three groups.
One is one and one is the other.
Okay.
That's a low resolution where the field isn't so uniform.
But if you make the field really,
really uniform,
if you tweak those knobs just right so that the peaks don't get broadened by
having different fields in different parts of the sample and in fact spin the
sample so that a given a given molecule actually is going around and sampling
different parts to average the field to make it even more uniform.
Right?
Then you see this thing with sharp peaks.
So it's the same three,
three,
two,
but they look a little different here,
right?
Uh,
so peak with does about three parts per billion,
right?
And that's as you see a single peak there.
But this next one is a little different.
That's a triplet one to two to one right?
So that's one of those ch three groups,
but which ch three group.
Oh at four pardon me?
I got it backwards.
This was a ch three group and it turns out to be this one.
This ch three group is splitted the three and it's that one.
Now why is it not a single peak?
What's different?
Right.
Okay,
well that's splitting is 0.029 parts per million.
I obviously blew it up in order to be able to see it clearly here.
And this is a 250 megahertz spectrum.
So it means that splitting the difference in frequency of protons in one
environment and the other is 7.3 hertz.
Right?
And it's exactly the same.
They're 7.3 hertz
right?
Now,
if you look here,
that's a quartet,
right?
And those are 7.3 hertz as well.
All right.
Now,
what's that last signal?
This little tiny one down here.
We'll notice that the solvent is c d c l three.
Now,
why would they pay the bucks,
the big bucks to get deuterium rather than just using normal flora forms?
C H C l three for a solvent?
What would it look like if the solvent were CHC,
l three,
you'd have an enormous peak from the solvent that hydrogen at the solvent,
right?
It would wash out the other things.
So you make it do pterygium,
but it's not 100% duty area and there's a tiny,
tiny amount of protium in there,
right?
So that tiny signal comes from a little bit of ch three on the solvent.
Okay.
So the 90 degree Paul's makes the spinning nuclei broadcast of frequency that
tells their local magnetic field,
right?
In a uniform field.
Now there's the big uniform field,
but what the nucleus sees is an effective local magnetic field,
which is of course the big field.
That's mostly it,
but little,
little tiny differences due to the chemical environment.
And let's see what those,
how we do it.
Okay.
Just to back up a first,
uh,
you could make the applied field in homogeneous as an MRI,
and then you make it in the field can be,
for example,
a three Tesla,
two Tesla,
30,000 gals with a gradient of four gals,
percent of meter for human samples.
And if you have a tiny thing,
you can make a bigger gradients.
So for small animals,
you can get 50 gallons per centimeters and do the imaging that we talked about.
But in chemistry it's different.
In chemistry,
you make it really homogeneous.
So the only differences come not from where the Proton is in the sample,
but from where it is in a molecule.
Okay.
And now we're interested in a molecular field that's added to or subtracted from
the big field.
And mostly it's subtracted from,
as you'll see.
So these molecular fields then tell you about the molecular environment,
these tiny shifts.
So there are two sources of these local magnetic fields besides the enormous big
field that you put on.
One is electrons orbiting.
Now the electrons come in,
payers that tend to orbit in opposite directions,
right?
So they tend to cancel,
but there's a little bit of excess for reasons we don't need to go on to have
one orbiting over the other.
So you get effects from electron orbiting and the,
the magnitude of this shift is about 12 parts per million for protons or 200
parts per million per carbon.
The different,
the range of values you can get from that.
Right?
Which is,
so this is grossly exaggerated.
It should be only parts per million of this,
not,
you know,
like a,
a 20th or something like that,
or a 10th okay.
So one thing about the environment,
how many electrons are around doing this orbiting.
The other thing is there are other magnetic nuclei nearby who have fields too.
So if you're this proton or listening for this Proton,
it's field is not only going to be the big field,
not only what's coming from the electrons orbiting,
but also what's coming from other nuclei that are in the vicinity being oriented
either this way or this way.
Okay.
And those we measure in Hertz and you'll see why we measure one in parts per
million.
And the other in hurts very soon.
Okay.
So anyhow,
when you add all those things together,
you get an effective field and that's what determines the frequency of the
signal you're going to hear.
Okay.
So first we're going to talk about the chemical shift.
What happens from orbiting?
Okay,
so electron orbiting gives this little red B,
but the reason the electrons orbit is because of the applied field and the
bigger the applied field,
the bigger the orbiting.
Right?
So that says the Redfield is proportional to the blue field.
If you may,
if you spent the money to get a bigger magnet,
you'd get twice as much orbiting.
So the red would be the same.
So that says that,
uh,
so what you measure then is a fractional thing because it's not a standard
difference.
It depends on how big your magnet is.
If you make your magnet twice as big,
the shift is twice as big.
The red field is twice as big,
so it's a fraction of the big ones.
So you measure it in parts per million,
right?
In a fractional unit rather than an absolute unit,
like an energy unit like hurts.
Okay,
so here's a scale of parts per million.
Let's see what different values we have.
Okay.
Now the standard that's used is called tms,
Tetra Methyl siling.
Now,
why you such a weird molecule is your standard.
Well,
it's a small molecule and it's volatile,
so you can add a drop to your sample,
but you can easily get it out.
Again if you want to recover your sample because it evaporates easily.
Okay?
Now all it has four ch three groups,
but they're all identically situated.
So it will just give one peak,
okay?
Rather than a more complicated molecules.
So that's good.
But the thing that's really special is that the silicon is being a metal is
partially plus,
and the methyl is largely minus,
which means they're more electrons around the protons,
which means there's a bigger shielding.
This B is bigger than it would be if there were fewer electrons around.
So it shifted all the way to one end of the spectrum.
So it doesn't overlap.
Other things that you might have in your sample.
So you have a standard then that you can use to call what to do with high
electron density around the protons,
which defines zero,
right?
And now you get another peak from your sample and see where it is compared to
this.
For example,
if you have a carboxylic acid,
the h on a carboxylic acid is way what's called downfield.
Why?
Why is it very different from the hydrogen in tms?
Anybody see why the Coh hydrogen might be different?
The environment of it,
right?
The OAH is electron withdrawing,
especially with the carbon eel group on it,
right?
So the electrons get stepped away from the hydrogen.
You don't have as much of that red shielding effect.
So it's,
it's shifted way down to the other end.
Okay.
Now,
so on the right,
it said to be shielded.
That is the electrons around the proton cancel the big field,
but only a teeny bit of it.
Only a few parts per million.
Right?
Okay.
Whereas,
and it's called up field and it's also a place where there's high electron
density and it's what called a low chemical shift.
This scale is,
is the chemical shift numbers.
And that's defined to zero.
So it's a very low number,
right?
And it's also low frequency,
Because we have lots of electrons,
relatively big value here.
There is very small,
relatively small electric magnet effective field,
relatively small,
so a low precession frequency,
not such a big field.
Okay.
By contrast,
the Oah is called de shielded downfield,
low electron density,
high chemical shift,
that high frequency.
Now if you have a car,
a proton that's attached to a normal carbon,
not one that's attached to silicon,
which is giving electrons away,
right?
Then it comes around one or between a half and two.
And the way these were found just by putting different known samples in and
seeing where the peaks came,
okay,
okay?
But if you have oxygen halogen or nitrogen attached to the carbon in the same
way that silicon donated electrons,
the carbon,
these electronegative atoms take electrons from the carbon,
which take electrons from the hydrogen,
which make the smaller,
which shifted downfield.
So in that region,
between two and a half and four and a half.
Okay?
Now,
if you have,
if it's attached to,
if the carbon to which the hydrogen is attached is itself attached to a carbon,
not to one of these electric negative elements,
but that carbon has oxygen on it,
then the oxygen is such sucking electrons from carbon,
from carbon,
from hydrogen.
So it shifted down a little bit.
So a hydrogen on a carbon attached to a carbon eel is inbetween there,
right?
If you have a carbon attached to a double bond,
it's shifted down still further.
Now,
why should a carb,
why should a hydrogen attached to a double bond be different from a,
from a carbon,
with a double bond be different from a hydrogen attached to a carbon with only
single bonds?
What difference?
Maybe
it's not the p.
Well,
actually to tell you the truth,
it probably is the Pi Bond,
but that's not the explanation that people usually give.
What other difference,
what differences there in the sigma system,
Leon?
Pardon me?
The hybridization,
right?
This is an SP squared,
More s more electron withdrawing,
whereas these carbons are Spq,
right?
So as you pull electrons to the carbon away from the hydrogen,
you shift down.
That makes sense.
In fact,
this you might expect would be the same.
It's shifted even a little further down.
All of these things were discovered empirically just by putting known samples in
and finding out where they come.
But you and then an Aldehyde is,
you won't be surprised to hear is still further down because it has the ox,
it's not only double bonded,
it has an oxygen pulling away.
So all of these things more or less make sense in terms of electron withdrawal
or donation to the hydrogen.
Okay.
Uh,
but it's fact,
it's a little more subtle than that.
Now,
r o h uh,
is funny because it can come at lots of different positions depending on
concentration and depending on temperature,
why would concentration have anything to do with it?
Why would it have come in a different place if you had more ROI?
H Lauren,
if you have hydrogen bonding and that affects the chemical,
higher concentration,
more hydrogen bonding,
higher temperature,
less hydrogen bonding.
Right.
So that's,
so the o h comes at lots of different positions depending on those factors.
Okay.
So you can already see from this that if you take a spectrum and see peaks in
different positions,
you can try to say,
Aha,
this,
it looks like it has a hydrogens that are just attached to carbons that are all
single bonded.
It has doubled hydrogen on double bonded carbons,
blah,
blah.
You measure the integral and see how many of each kind there are and that you
can then do puzzles like the ones in that webpage that I mentioned,
uh,
to try to figure out what structures are.
Now,
let's see.
If you've learned from this,
where should you expect the hydrogen that it's attached to?
The carbon of an acetylene?
Where would you expect it to come?
What's special?
No.
Well you got any idea on this?
What's special about it?
It
the triple bonds.
So now how's the triple bond Gunno effect things?
Yeah.
Hi.
It'll affect the hybridization and in what way?
Yeah,
it'll be s p right?
It'll be an sp hybrid,
which is more electron withdrawing then sp squared,
then sp cubed.
So it should be pulling electrons away.
D shielding,
as you say,
because the electrons are shielding.
So it should shift to the left compared to the double bond funds.
Right?
Wrong.
Okay.
It actually comes up there.
So there's more to it than what we're saying now.
What is this more to it?
Uh,
unfortunately that the clock is wrong,
so you're going to have to wait for tomorrow to find that out.